[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
point de vue je vous présente les deux
invités qui ont accepté de participer ce
soir christophe de bob bonjour bonjour
vous êtes professeur de rhétorique à
sciences po et face à vous ce soir
jean-christophe buisson
j'hésite à vous présenter tout le monde
vous connaît mais bon quand même le
directeur adjoint eelv à cigares au
magazine et on vous retrouve dans le fig
mag de cette semaine avec un reportage
d'être retourné une deuxième fois en
arménie
oui surtout on en est des parties une
première fois il ya trois semaines avec
sylvain tesson et dernier jour du
conflit
et là j'y suis retourné pour accompagner
la délégation française
parce que si la france n'a pas été au
rendez vous de l'histoire d'un gain lié
en tout cas dans l'après-guerre en
important une aide très précieuse sur le
pays dans un état mais catastrophique
d'un point de vue sanitaire médicale et
humanitaire et la france là est vraiment
vraiment au rendez vous avec notamment
youri djorkaeff qui est ambassadeur de
bonne volonté pour l'arménie nommé par à
emmanuel macron et qui se démène avec
d'autres et la fondation en savoure le
fonds arménien de france pour aider ces
quatre-vingt mille arméniens chassés de
leurs terres équivalent à leur tour
n'auront sans doute pas du haut karabakh
donc un reportage à lire et à voir parce
qu'il ya un reproche photo également
d'un photographe qui était sur place qui
a suivi tout lantoine agondjé encore là
bas alors nous avons sélectionné deux
thèmes dans l'actualité qui s'impose
évidemment parce que emmanuel macron et
en ce moment donc il nous fait un peu
une concurrence mais à mon avis on
l'écrasé en audience voilà on va le
dépasser
emmanuel macron en fait-il trop en
termes de communication après
l'intervention au 20 heures hier et un
second thème
lié aussi de l'actualité est ce que ce
qu'il faudrait pas accélérer un
déconfinement est-ce qu'on doit pas
aller plus vite donc je vous propose le
premier thème une intervention à 20
heures hier soir pour rendre hommage à
valéry giscard d'estaing une émission
spéciale en direct si on déjeune sur ce
réseau social
cette cette chaîne qui s'appelle brut
c'était à 16h beaucoup de messages sur
twitter à skis emmanuel macron en fait
trop je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de son intervention d'hier à 20
heures il a regardé notre pays en phase
avec les yeux d'une génération nouvelle
qui a voulu le progrès sans sacrifier de
sa liberté sans que nous en ayons
toujours conscience nous marchons dans
ses pas son septennat a marqué notre
pays et nos vies toute entière
christophe de boxe vous avez j'imagine
regardé hier ou peut-être vu des
extraits alors vous avez été touchés par
ce discours d' emmanuel macron sur en
hommage à valéry giscard d'estaing a
malheureusement j'ai pu la spontanéité
de la découverte
non c'était un magnifique autoportrait
et comme souvent d'ailleurs celle
emmanuel macron c'est un autoportrait
tous les maux qui ont été dit si vous
réussi à vous les prenez absolument tous
l'europe la jeunesse le dynamisme la
génération nouvelle quand le plus tard
possible emmanuel macron quittera ce
monde ce seront les mots que que dirar
son successeur
pour le groupe renault même thackeray
donc ça ne te portrait magnifique et
toujours un sous texte comme ça chez
emmanuel macron est aussi un deuxième ce
texte qui va nous conduire peut-être a
aussi un autre notre thème brut si j'ose
dire qui est toujours l'insistance qui
me frappe de plus en plus dans ses
dernières interventions d'assistance sur
la jeunesse ou là et vu là mais il a
même réussi à le faire sur daniel
cordier daniel cordier qui est quand
même centenaire mais nous a remis daniel
cordier à 20 ans l'éternel jeune homme
ou sonner de sahin et il a parlé de
cette jeunesse de ses enfants jeunes
mais héroïques déjà des héros est
évidemment là on voit très bien que
depuis un moment et de façon je dirais
intelligentes
emmanuel macron est en train de viser de
plus en plus l'électorat jeune est ce
qu'il est en train de faire en ce moment
même le confirme jean christophe buisson
alors est ce qu'il en fait pas un peu
trop
oui en fait un peu trop sur son discours
discours votre giscard je pense qu'une
part de ya une grande part de calcul
une grande part de calcul pour les
raisons que je viens de dire christophe
d'autoportraits il ya un calcul aussi
qui est ouf un échappatoire à ce qui se
passe en ce moment avec la loi sécurité
avec darmanin avec l'article 24
il se reproche qu'on lui fait d'être de
pencher un peu trop à droite giscard
c'est formidable ça ça va se caler entre
l'hommage à de gaulle
cette année à l'hommage à mitterrand
l'année prochaine il a trouvé celui du
centre qu'il incarnait au combien
jusqu'à pour pouvoir dire regardez ce
giscard c'est aussi l'homme du progrès
de la jeunesse des réformes donc moi
évidemment et donc ça permet de remettre
un petit peu le curseur plus au centre
voire plus à gauche que qu'il n'est
supposé l'être actuellement notamment
etc darmanin un peu droit dans ses
bottes et avec ses lois liberticides de
confinement de loi sécurité globale donc
ça tombait très bien donc il ya vraiment
sépare de calcul mais je pense qu'il est
vraiment le père de sincérité et parce
que parce que vous venez de dire c'est
vraiment un autoportrait et quand il
commence en disant je suis né dans les
années giscard je suis on sent que c'est
quelque chose de personnel est que jusqu
à décoincer quelque chose en france sur
le plan sociétal est justement le
sociétal c'est ce qui caractérise macron
dans ce qu'il a de gauche pour aller
vite donc c'est évident qu'il est
sincère lorsqu'il salue le progrès pour
les femmes et c'est vraiment ce qu'il
pense sur le fond et ça tombe bien c'est
aussi politiquement 1a qui lui permet de
se réinscrire d'où le fait d'en faire
une grand messe du 20h qui est qui pour
le répondre à votre question je vais
faire un long des poèmes et fort mon
avis trop oui c'est évidemment trop
c'est évidemment trop d'un point de vue
purement rationnel mais pour les raisons
que je viens de dire ça lui paraissait
évident de le faire l'autre raison étant
que je pense qu'il estime que son
premier ministre et un petit peu brûlé
en ce moment et qu'il faut qu'ils
reprennent la main ça tombe bien on est
dans des monarchies républicaines ou un
moulin à paroles du chef d'état est
supposé comptait plus que celle du chef
du gouvernement
donc on va pas se priver de cette
occasion de cette occasion qui en plus
quelque chose qui est plutôt à son
avantage alors que castex est plutôt là
pour les nouvelles un peu moins d'un an
bonne nouvelle vous vous évoquez
christophe de voc là la préoccupation du
chef de l'état sur la jeunesse si on est
cynique on se dit les jeunes c'est pas
ceux qui votent le plus sale et 18
24 ans 1 c'est pas forcément l'électorat
de macron qui était plutôt sur un
électorat de retraités en 2017 et les
jeunes aujourd'hui votre plus donc c'est
quoi son intérêt de s'adresser aux
jeunes mais écoutez les les élections
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent l'élection 2022 et mener ma
croix l'intelligence politique de
comprendre qu'elle n'a rien n est pas
gagné que tout est possible
vous savez à la fondapol on a montré à
quel point la volatilité la polarisation
des lecteurs a été considérable et que
ça peut partir dans tous les sens on
peut parler d'un craindre un commandé un
accident électoral
emmanuel macron à qui on peut on peut
reprocher de tout ce qu'on veut est un
animal politique de haute volée il l'a
prouvé
c'est un grand lecteur de machiavel il
en est spécialiste le but toujours il a
consacré à machiavel sa maîtrise donc il
sait comment fonctionne la politique
le théâtre de la politique car ce qu'on
appelle la communication c'est
finalement le bon vieux théâtre de la
politique et il s'est donc à la fois
être dans l'utile
est dans le vrai comme vous disiez si
bien en même temps donc je crois qu'il
faut absolument essayer de comprendre
qu'ils anticipent l'élection alors les
jeunes adorent quand même il a eu pas
mal de votre jeune en 2010 est surtout
deuxième tour évidemment mais c'est sûr
que le premier vote jeunes on le sait
bien c'est l'abstention et que le reste
va quand même très largement souad à
l'extrême gauche soit vers l'extrême
droite et que donc il ya quand même là
quelques quelques voix à glaner et je
crois aussi alors là toujours en vérité
qu'il a conscience que les jeunes
aujourd'hui ils ne vont pas très bien il
suffit de voir des étudiants ont des
enfants pour le savoir la crise
l'épidémie de la crise et lille il a
émis des perspectives
donc il sait quand même que il ya là à
la fois un risque est peut-être une
chance c'est à dire de parler parce que
finalement peu d'autres peuvent parler à
cette jeunesse et notamment pour la
rassurer
économiquement macro note encore koch
bien la case économique
vous savez que fait le monde le sait
l'élection 2022 ce sera économie
sécurité grosso modo un nom macro coach
très bien la case économies dans
l'esprit des français est moins bien la
case sécurité c'est sûr mais c'est pas
la case qui touche le plus les jeunes
sécurité ce qui les enquêtes luz elle
donne la touche peut-être un des rues de
manière différente différents noms et
puis qu'est-ce qui prouve qu est ce qui
peut pousser les jeunes aujourd'hui qui
s'abstiennent à voter en 2022 leur
avenir économique
non l'extrême droite au second tour la
lutte contre l'extrême raoui pour pour
cette jeunesse là bas oui bon c'est géré
comme on l'a mobilisent au premier tour
mais moi je parle encore ce qui
contrarie le deuxième taux fin marine le
pen je pense en tout cas je pense c'est
le calcul qui peut faire en disant je
prépare le terrain et lorsque je serai
le barrage contre l'extrême droite cette
jeunesse-là préférera quand même
emmanuel macron au spectre de
l'extraliga qui prend le pouvoir en
france on est d'accord moi je suis
persuadé qu'elle mène ma conjointe
combat de premier tour à quoi à quoi est
ce que on le voit on le voit à cette
droitisation elle avait que 50
guillemets en tout cas apparente il
s'agit quand même pour lui d'éliminer
toute hypothèse à droite
se qualifier pour se qualifier au
deuxième tour c'est ça et je pense qu'il
est il est moins optimiste que beaucoup
de maquereaux n'ya que beaucoup
d'analystes et que je pense qu'il est
plus prudent et qu'il sait que le combat
va être rude
donc il faut notamment mais dans ce cas
même n'aurait pas cherché pour un jeune
c'est bon notamment il serait pas mal
d'en prendre une bonne partie de ceux
qui ont voté mélenchon de lanières fois
alors s'ils étaient nombreux
ouais bah c'est pas pour ranger les
chiffres de droite marine le pen
mélenchon était en tête dans les 18 34
ans en 2 mai donc c'est pas à droite on
se comprend bien
en même temps on se dit qu il constitue
mais ça c'est typiquement un réservoir
il essaie de constituer pas sa parole
personnelle un vote jeunes en sa faveur
je dis pas que ça marche là bas on verra
d'abord l'audience de l'émission
d'aujourd'hui qui nous fait concurrence
je le rappelle mais qu'on écrasera ce
brut des premières images pas si vous
les avez vus ils ne cèdent rien sur la
violence est évidemment il a fini par
céder sur la violence policière parce
qu'il était tellement harcelée le pauvre
ouais c'est un tennis est intéressant ce
qu'il disait les enjeux je vois bien que
le terme violence policière est en train
d'être récupérées notamment parti
d'extrême gauche qui sous-entend un côté
systémique c'est à dire il y à des
violences policières lille non il ya des
violences des policiers la police n'est
pas raciste il ya des racistes dans la
police la police des menaces violentes
en swahili à des violences la police
il essayait de défendre sa fille à pied
et en face il a il avait encore il ya
cinq ans même rémy buisine qui lui dit
mais attendez il ya trois ans vous
parliez de violences policières donc
qu'est ce qui a changé pour bon ben si
vous voulez je veux dire violences
policières il asséné il a craqué c'est
pour ça que j'ai vu je suis pas sûr que
c'était une bonne idée parce que il est
obligé ce ne sont pas des journalistes
professionnels qui vont prendre
rémy buzine il s'en fiche il va lui il
veut lui faire dire aux violences
policières et à la fin emmanuel macron a
dit si vous voulez je le dis à des
violences policières
donc tout son argumentation de dix
minutes de 10000 précédente s'est
effondré il faudrait je pense que toutes
les missions va être sur ce ton là c'est
tout le droit de l'est mais que vous
pointiez du en même temps c'est à dire
qu'en effet il y là il a plutôt une
stratégie de parler à l'électorat de
droite encore une fois pour empêcher
parce que c'est quand même le danger est
là mais il veut en même temps justement
avoir autant de voix de jeune que
possible tout en profitant de
l'effondrement possible de mélenchon
voyez l'idée
et donc notamment jouant le sociétal en
jouant beaucoup de thèmes qui peuvent
pas aller à une certaine jeunesse tandis
que l'autre partie de la jeunesse on le
sait contrairement à ce qu'on pense il
ya une partie de la jeunesse importante
qui va te marine le pen de toutes façons
de 2012 celle là elle est irrécupérable
pour macron juste donc on a posé la
question aux auditeurs et aux
internautes
est-ce que emmanuel macron fait trop de
communication 67%
vous avez répondu oui il en fait trop
j'aurais sauf qu'ils sont à une époque
jacques pilhan conseiller de trailer et
puis voilà
pour françois mitterrand avait théorisé
la rareté la rolls présidentielle bon là
on n'est évidemment pas dans la même
période mais est-ce que macron fait une
erreur on en revient à notre thème en
faisant trop de communication pour être
aujourd'hui pour être honnête c'est en
même temps une question de timing cette
semaine
la mort de giscard wright n'est pas
spécialement prévu dans son agenda et je
pense qu'ils s'étaient préparés vraiment
pour se parler aux jeunes
avec cette émission brute pour revenir
sur les violences policières il ya dû
avoir lieu hier
j'aurais dû avoir lieu absolument et
donc le fait de rajouter giscard le
jeudi brut le vendredi troubles un 2e
son agenda et qu'à cette idée de rareté
la parole présidentielle mais pour
autant ils avaient commencé quand même
il a besoin de briser cette idée oui
vous voulez vu au début de son cd de son
quinquennat il parlait quasiment plus au
journaliste classiques comme vous qui
suivez la politique depuis 20 ans il
avait décidé de se maintenir très loin
il est revenu sur cette idée mais sur le
par les crises successives qui était
assez inédite pour pour être honnête
donc je pense qu'il se laisse à peu
dicté par les événements parce qu'il n'a
moins de choix et je voudrais avant que
vous réussissiez je voudrais vous faire
écouter ce que disait ce matin au toc
olivier marleix scx le vice président
des républicains
et c'est justement ici même à votre
place sur la segmentation des prises de
paroles de d'emmanuel macro ont écouté
le fil des interviews cet après-midi
d'ailleurs dans un sur un site qui
s'appelle brut pour destinée plus
particulièrement s'adresser à la
jeunesse
oui il aime bien il a une drôle drôle de
méthode qui consiste à changer de deux
médias en fonction des cibles moi
j'écris aussi qu'à l'occasion ils
changent de discours et d'un jours un
discours très ferme sur l'immigration
dans valeurs actuelles
et puis le quelques jours après il
rassure les lecteurs de libération
entonnant notre discours je ne peux pas
gouverner un pays comme ça on peut pas
remettre de l'ordre un pays comme ça je
crains qui manque vraiment de conviction
et de colonne vertébrale alors sur cette
question-là de la segmentation est ce
que est ce que j'aime à croire raison
alors là les ailes et les spécialistes
de communication vous diront sans doute
oui puisque c'est le qu'il conseille moi
je moi je n'y crois pas vous dites moi
je pense que la cohérence du discours
est menacé mon côté old school la
cohérence du discours est une chose qui
pour un homme politique est décisive
mais il ya plus je crois que là je vais
aller un petit peu au-delà de ce que
vous avez dit jean-christophe c'est la
question du des circonstances moi je
crois que la principale circonstances
qui fait que macro on reparle beaucoup
et là je vais être un petit peu plus
peut-être un peu plus dur avec lui c'est
le fait que son premier ministre ne peut
pas parler et quand il y avait des
douars philippe
cette neige ça tenait le coup bon là le
vrai problème maintenant c'est qu'on a
affaire à la défaillance rhétorique du
premier ministre qu'a plein de qualités
par ailleurs mais qui n'est quand même
pas démosthène et je pense que cette
cette défaillance du premier ministre
est là emmanuel mac va être très
envieuse de plus en plus ennuyeuse parce
que dame fortune pour parler comme
machiavel va continuer à visiter
l'histoire
1 alors jusqu'à la mort hier mais un
autre va mourir demain il va y avoir
ceci cela l'attentât est-ce que emmanuel
macron va parler à chaque fois parce que
son premier ministre ne peut pas parler
et dans tous les sens du mot ne peut pas
parler et là je crois que là ils payent
et mâcon paie son propre choix
en voulant choisir c'est souvent le
drame de la deuxième partie des
septénaires ou des quinquennats
en voulant choisir un premier ministre
de l'ombre et dans l'ombre et qu'il ne
fasse pas d'ombré
eh bien il prend le risque de s'exposer
et et je pense que aussi doué soit il il
sait qu'il est doux et nous savons tous
qu'il est doué aussi uruguay soit il je
crains que là vraiment il aille vers la
surexposition donc vers le coup de
soleil
entièrement d'accord alors bah écoute et
nicole qui nous suivent attentivement et
d'accord avec vous il en fait trop à mon
goût à tel point que je ne l'écouté je
ne le regarde plus et elle va plus
longtemps de macron dit à ses
interlocuteurs ce qu'ils veulent
entendre pour moi il n'y a rien de sain
ça est la preuve elle regarde point de
vue plutôt que brut et et c'est un très
bon choix
vous avez entièrement raison et du coup
on peut passer à notre notre deuxième
thème
ce déconfinement est-ce qu'il faut
l'accélérer normalement la deuxième
étape était prévu pour le vin est
toujours prévu d'ailleurs pour le 15
décembre et ce qu'il faudrait pas aller
un peu plus vite
on voit que les chiffres s'améliorent le
fameux airs 0 ce chiffre qui permet de
savoir combien de gens sont contaminés
elle est tombée à 0.58 bas écouté hier
jean castex a pas semblé vraiment de cet
avis je vous propose de l'écouter
c'était pendant sa conférence de presse
ces mesures ont été je le sais bien dur
pour nombre d'entre vous mais elle était
nécessaire et reste encore nécessaire
car la situation reste fragile
le niveau de circulation du virus est le
nombre de personnes en réanimation reste
ainsi supérieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
en mai dernier lorsque nous avons des
confiné nous ne sommes pas encore venu à
bout de ce virus et nous devons rester
mobilisés
la situation reste fragile on doit
rester mobilisés vous êtes d'accord avec
les propos de jean castex
il faut pas des confiné plus vite que ce
qui est prévu à la salle buisson d'abord
je pense qu on a commencé ce dès confiné
sans attendre que l'état nous en donne
l'autorisation si on en juge par ce
qu'on peut voir dans les rues de paris
et d'ailleurs
par ailleurs je note et moi c'est ce qui
me choque le plus que en martinique
le 8 décembre le déconfinement sera
effectif avec couvre-feu et ce qui
m'amène à cette interrogation pourquoi
on ne décentralise pas enfin
ce confinement par par région par ville
pour qu'on ne décide pas que tel endroit
effectivement peut être raisonnablement
des confiné avant le 15 décembre ou
après le 15 décembre pourquoi cette
centralisation jacobinisme sanitaire
kiné qui est tellement aberrant qu'on
l'a brisée mais alors on se dit que la
martinique on va ça va pas se remarquer
parce que c'est loin c'est l'autre côté
de l'atlantique pardon la martinique
c'est la france donc si on peut le faire
en martinique pourquoi en pole on peut
pas le faire pourquoi la savoie la
haute-savoie font partie d'une région
qui est très contaminée qui est qui qui
justifie peut-être qu'on empêche les
remontées mécaniques mais les pyrénées à
ce que je sache ne sont pas dans le même
état que les alpes alors pourquoi on ne
permettrait pas aux pyrénées
d'accueillir dans les retours dans les
remontées mécaniques des touristes
puisque le taux d'incidence de
circulation n'est pas le même cette idée
de ce que tout le monde soit la même
enseigne c'est que cette folie
égalitariste qui nous habite depuis deux
siècles montre il me semble ses limites
existent pauvre castex est obligé de
justifier l'injustifiable c'est à dire
tout le monde au plus bas tout le monde
punis et une économie qui s'est fondée
la pression se demande pourquoi
l'économie s'effondre je comprends pas
ce jacobinisme permanent christophe
devaux je crois vous avez à peu donné la
réponse
iliad est évidemment le jacobinisme c
et ils savent faire que ça on est
d'accord une loi une norme pour tout le
monde et mes yeux une autre raison qui
me paraît plus subtile et je trouve
qu'on évoque que vous avez évoquées et
qu'on évoque trop peu vous l'avez
mentionné quand vous n'êtes pas être
l'égalitarisme depuis deux siècles
c'est à dire que moi j'avoue que j'ai
j'ai une interrogation un peu un peu
perfide qui est le problème de ce que
tocqueville appelait l'envi la jalousie
démocratique
rappelez vous quand on a pendant le
premier confinement interdit les plages
il était une sottise sanitaire je parle
même pas une d'une sottise politique
mais une sottise sanitaire puisque il
est mieux que les gens et sur les plages
plutôt qu il reste confiné bon les parcs
de paris rappelez vous tout ça quand on
a fermé les magasins vous savez les
rayons des grands magasins pas ce qu'ont
affirmé les petits commerces
c'est égalitarisme parle par le bas j'ai
une question un petit peu sacrilège
est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose qui
réjouit est finalement beaucoup de gens
qui satisfait beaucoup de gens et est ce
que là il n'y a pas un calcul politique
qui est de dire eh bien on va pas rendre
les gens des alpes jaloux des gens des
pyrénées alors que dans un pays normal
dans un pays équitable on va dire
évidemment on serait ravis que les gens
des pyrénées face du ski d'ailleurs
venir faire du ski dans les pyrénées ou
soit d'ailleurs
estrosi en a parlé à propos de d'ead
maritimes 10 actuellement très peu
contaminés et simplement l'idée que
quand même pas l'autre il est en train
de skier et gino un peu parce que
l'autre il peut aller sur la plage et
quand vous interrogez des décideurs ça
m'est arrivé
la vraie motivation de ces mesures là
était une motivation une motivation
politique égalitariste pour prônent par
ja dire pour ne pas désespérer non plus
billancourt mais la courneuve ou là ou
de saint pierre ce qui plaît de danse
que vous expliquer c'est que
au début de cette deuxième phase le
gouvernement a essayé de régionaliser
quand ils ont fait un nouveau feu à
marseille et bordeaux et paris et que
tous les élus de marseille ont hurlé en
disant mais pourquoi nous c'est encore
les paris c'est aussi nous on l'avait
pas prévenue avant c'était presque plus
beaucoup de raisons mais il y avait il
ya un peu seul aspect là alors il ya
d'une part le jacobinisme on sait faire
comme ça on sait faire que ça mais il ya
aussi ces vieilles égalitarisme français
qui préfèrent que l'autre souffrent
autant que vous plutôt que kiel
naissance à risquer ce qui est gênant
c'est aussi l'absence de deux de recul
ou cet orgueil mal placé parce que ce
qu'on a bien vu pendant les premiers
confinement c'est que des initiatives
locales de certains maires de certaines
collectivités je pense notamment david
lisnard à cannes
ils ont pris les choses en main ils ont
du bon hockey l'état donné des reins et
cetera on va essayer de se débrouiller
tout seul on va essayer d'organiser les
services de telle manière que l'on lutte
contre la pandémie avec nos moyens sans
attendre tout de l'état que ce soit de
l'argent des aides des fonctionnaires et
ils ont réussi et même le gouvernement a
salué ces initiatives de certains élus
qui sont qui ont réussi tout en restant
dans un cadre évidemment légal et
légitime à endiguer à leur manière avec
les moyens locaux beaucoup plus
compétents parce qu'ils savent
exactement de quels moyens disposent de
quelles ressources dispose de quelle
énergie dispose localement pourquoi
cette leçon n'ait pas retenu pourquoi
dans le 2ème confinement se dit bah on
se dit pas alors ça a été promis en
disant on va plus écouter les mers va
plus écouter les collectivités locales
par connaissent le terrain mais zéro
sauf en martinique martinique
bienheureux martiniquais était confiné
le lui décembre on peut par tous partis
en martinique c'est ça remplacera bien
oui il ya de la pub en ce moment pour la
martinique qui nous aime donc c'est
parfait mais je crois donc
malheureusement que c'est raisons
politiques
pèse n'avoir inavouables mais il s'est
un peu un non-dit entre entre le pouvoir
et le peuple qui moi d'ailleurs
m'inquiète un peu
alors nicole qui vivent et des
alpes-maritimes ce que nicole 06 ni bien
sûr et comme le dit jean christophe
buisson le déconfinement devrait se
faire par régions mais nos internautes
sont quand même très nombreux en
majorité plus prudent en disant que le
confinement ne doit pas être plus rapide
à 54 9 %
on voit bien quand même qu'il ya il ya
une crainte on aimerait bien aider
confiné mais le virus fait encore peur
non alors bien évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs c'est le fond du sujet quand
même c'est le van du sujet surtout
serait intéressant de savoir aussi l'âge
l'âge de ceux qui écoutent
parce que plus on avance en âge et plus
plus on a cette crainte
je pense que il ya ça je pense qu'il ya
la peur aussi parce que quelle est la
motivation il peut y avoir la peur de
passer à un faire un nouveau confinement
alors voilà donc il peut y avoir aussi
de très bonnes raisons d'être prudent je
pense quand même que vu les chiffres et
des chiffres qu'on aura au 15 décembre
et là où je me trompe fort mais comme
emmanuel macron est bien annoncer la
bonne nouvelle est que jean castex n'a
aucun problème pour annoncer les
mauvaises
je pense moi qu'on aura une bonne
surprise au 15 décembre sur un point
rappelez-vous d'ailleurs quand emmanuel
macron à accélérer certaines mesures de
déconfinement je pense je pense que il
va arriver quand même avec le cas de
noël pour être honnête il était quand
même obligé d'attendre pour répondre à
la première question initiale d'attentes
que les quinze jours se passe après
le
l'ouverture des primaires sera là samedi
dernier donc c'est obligé d'attendre le
week-end prochain
pendant le week-end prochain on est
quasiment 15 décembre donc ce n'était
pas idiot comme raisonnement et là on
discute de ça mais c'est qu'ils m'ont
les chiffres on commençait correspond
pas à la réalité du moment mais arrêtez
d'il ya quinze jours puisqu'une décision
a été prise d'ouvrir les commerces il ya
huit jours il faut quand même attendre
huit jours pour être sûr que cette
décision n'a pas réenclencher 9 ans et
que aussi que c'est pas le bon ce sera
bien sûr ce pas ce qui va dans votre
sens et le chiffre d'hier à la limite
plaide pour qu ils pas forcément
déconfinement plus rapide c'est le
nombre de contaminations par jour
emmanuel macron a fixé la georgie à 5000
et on voit passer à 1 déconfinement un
couvre-feu
il y est on était à douze mille neuf
cent a fait ça veut dire que
il va falloir faire un gros effort sur
la semaine qui vient vous êtes patron de
la culture aussi au fig mag
ils sont très inquiets les gens du ce
milieu là parce que au fond si on est
encore à 12000 ça veut dire que
peut-être il y aura des mauvaises
nouvelles pour noël et en tout cas pas
de réouverture de salles mais sur nos
longs et surtout dessous tous les
théâtres et beaucoup de petits théâtres
qui hésitent à ouvrir parce que les
conditions les protocoles sanitaires
sont encore plus féroce qu'en septembre
donc est-ce que ça vaudra le coup de
marie s'interrogent tous les films du
film sont encore à nouveau décalée au
moins février et mars les grands films
donc les salles de cinéma vont rouvrir
mais pour quelles offres et quel public
parce que comme vous l'avez rappelé tony
ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui ont
peur du virus donc même si les salles
sont ouvertes même si on leur garantit
un protocole sanitaire de grande ampleur
ils ne sortiront pas ils attendront que
y est les vaccins et des vaccins pour
finir ça va être intéressant de voir cet
égalitarisme que nous dénonçons comment
le gouvernement va gérer le fait qu'il y
aura bien des gens qui seront quand même
vacciner en priorité les personnes sur 4
des crédits
on a trois et voilà parce que
le curseur va être mis sur certains
métiers sur certaines tranches d'âge sur
berlin certains militent et pierre
mengelle madiabel l'huile est un tout
petit il presque dans la on va voir si
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont intérêt à
fournir beaucoup de vaccins d'un coup et
peut être pas faire trop séquencer sinon
ils vont avoir droit aux même reproches
oui je crois qu'ils ont tenté d'éviter
oui je crois qu'on va quand même vers le
troisième problème on a eu les masques
le test va voir on va avoir le problème
des vaccins déjà vous on n'ose pas trop
le dire mais le calendrier qui a été
annoncé hier c'est quand même trois mois
de retard sur nos voisins non sur un
voisin c'est l'angleterre qui sur
l'allemagne
oui car le grand souci c'est quand même
trois maillots tarder en difficulté les
allemands vont commencer des magnifiques
des vaccinations massives en janvier
massive nous on fera des masques et des
vaccinations massives au printemps un
temps 1 donc on a trois mois de retard
je ne veux pas être de mauvais augure
mais je crois que nous sommes en train
de préparer le thé troisième mais est ce
que m
mais de cela le mind va pas réussir à
faire des vaccinations massives parce
qu'elle avait fédéral et parce qu'on va
faire la région qui a besoin de vaccin
et personnes discutera la pertinence de
vacciner plus tôt les gens qui sont les
plus malades que les autres plutôt le le
schleswig-holstein que le la thuringe où
je ne sais quoi toi dis ça dans le plan
castex
non non mais là bas on en revient et on
revient au problème jacobinisme alors
rania sur youtube nous dit qu'il faut
renforcer le corps médical et procéder
aux déconfinement du pays le plus tôt
possible
mais amélie elle sur youtube toujours
lui dit non pas besoin de précipiter les
choses donc on voit bien avancée quand
même il ya une forte majorité 54 9 qui
veulent pas d'un déconfinement plus
rapide
je vous propose aussi de regarder la
question du jour du figaro parce que
hier dans la conférence de presse de
jean castex
il y avait cette question va sept
recommandations des pouvoirs publics de
10 rebonds
on sera en couvre feu sauf le 24 et le
31 décembre mais à ce moment là on va
essayer de ne pas dépasser une jauge de
six adultes à table les enfants ne
comptons pas dans cette jauge alors on a
demandé à ce que vous êtes favorable à
cette jauge de 6 voyez les résultats
bah écoutez c'est 50,4 on se croirait en
1974 élections présidentielles 50,4 qui
sont favorables à cette jauge 49.6 qui
ne sont pas favorables
est-ce que c'est d'un côté les familles
nombreuses à plus de 6
cette jauge vous trouvez qu'elle est
ridicule il faut aussi comme forme et
comment comment voyez les choses ça va
soupire qui ont dit non moi j'ai
l'argent qu'on peut pas la faire
respecter parce que j'ai une double
injection chantiers vont pas faire un
procès majeur là dessus d'abord le
premier ministre là dessus contrairement
à ce qu'on a dit a dit je recommence
ça n'a pas été fait comme si tu étais
vraiment pas son nom oh vous savez oui
on en a on a quand on est dans un pays
où on se fait à soi même une attestation
je crois que beaucoup de choses sont
possibles
donc dans la mesure distance où il
participe aussi aux pour nous envoyer
les agents de sécurité sociale vérifié
et c'est le 24 au soir non non agression
trop bien mais il ya toute façon il a
été donc prudent
le vrai problème que j'ai moi mais j'ai
cru un affreux libéral c'est que tout le
problème confinement déconfinement
mesure de ceux ci si c'est aussi subite
c'est que la question au départ est
illégitime
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas à la
liberté de se justifier voyez ce que je
veux dire on est déjà parti dans une
sorte de tunnel de restriction ou ont
négocié où on discute est ce que ces 6
ou 6 ennemis est ce que les enfants
comptait ce que nous ne sommes pas tous
des grands enfants et nous avons déjà
accepté le principe de la restriction de
liberté alors que vous savez que pour un
libéral la liberté première es7 aux
restrictions d'être justifiée c'est pour
ça que le vrai problème que moi j'ai
avec les mesures du confinement
c'est pas qu'on en prenne c'est évident
c'est que elles doivent être
impérativement justifier
la fermeture des petits commerces
n'était pas justifié la fermeture des
plages n'était pas justifié et le vrai
et ça c'est un problème de culture
démocratique je peux vous dire pour bien
fréquenté un certain nombre de pays du
nord de l'europe
ils nous regardent avec des yeux mais
absolument ébahi en disant mais comment
vous pouvez accepter ça et des pays
particulièrement disciplinés je pense
aux allemands je pense aux néerlandais
je pense aux danois c'est pas des
rigolos qui font n'importe quoi mais ils
nous disent mais on ne supporterait pas
ça trois minutes chez nous donc la
liberté peut être réduite tous les
libéraux le disent depuis toujours mais
à chaque fois c'est à la restriction
d'être justifié ce n'est pas à la
liberté de se justifier j'en reste aux
pulsions le mot de la fin
non dire qu'on aura quand même demain
encore des insoumis qui diront que la
france est un pays ultra libérale alors
qu'on a vu depuis dernières semaines ces
dernières semaines qu'on était sans
doute le pays le moins libérale de toute
l'europe et ben écoute et merci à vous
deux on termine sur cette dose de
liberté
et bah écoute et passer un bon week-end
et on se retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouvel nouveau numéro de point de vue
bonne soirée
[Musique]